I don't know kind of how it happens but
I think fundamentally it's all about
venture capital the more money that's
available and the more sort of the
culture is about going out and raising
money and the more it just happens and
it sort of feeds on itself if the
venture capitalist weren't there there'd
be a lot of empty companies that
wouldn't be there in that pod that I
think probably be better not in every
case but in most cases I think it's
better when your forces an entrepreneur
to bootstrap and here's the fundamental
reason why if you have two companies one
that's bootstraps one that's you know
self-funded one that's got venture
capital money in the bank the primary
difference is this on day one a
bootstrap company has to make money on
day one a funded company has to spend
money they have like money in the bank
to spend that's their first task is to
spend to hire to get a great beautiful
beautiful office to do all that stuff
that's what they have to do that to
spend money unlike a bootstrap company
that doesn't have my tits but I have to
make money first and I think that's the
right instinct for an entrepreneur to
start out with is the idea of I gotta
make money that's the right that's the
right thing and I think what happens is
especially in Silicon Valley where
there's a lot of spare money around
people are handing it out essentially
that you don't have the instinct the
instinct isn't built to make money the
instinct is built to spend money any of
that just kind of perpetuates itself and
people don't have to make money because
other people are paying for things until
the money runs out and then you're kind
of screwed then it's too late because
you don't have the skills to make money
so that's I think the problem with
Silicon Valley
well I think the thing is is that not
having money or having to make your own
forces you to make really smart
decisions and good decisions and makes
you think about stuff like for example
you know if you go out and what if you
win the lottery you're probably going to
make good decisions about how to spend
your money you've got a lot of it so you
just now buy a house I'll buy a boat
I'll buy this stuff like you're not
actually making decisions you're just
spending money but when you have very
limited resources you're forcing the
making decisions that makes sense does
it make sense for us to spend this money
on marketing we have it should we just
blow it or are we not gonna get a return
on it and you start to think about these
things and you start to find yourself
wondering like does it make sense to
hire 20 people or should we hire two we
can afford to hire two so let's hire to
really good people because that's all we
can do and when you're forced to like
forcing those constraints you just make
better decisions I always look at this
is probably weird analogy but I tend to
look at prisoners in jail how they make
these weapons or they'll take like a pen
and like a piece of tape and in a comb
and they make they can like break out of
prison with that but if someone had all
the money in the world to break out of
prison and they would like buy a
jackhammer and they would buy like you
know chisels and stuff they'd make too
much noise they attract too much
attention and it wouldn't work they have
all the resources but they'd spend them
they wouldn't spend them wisely but the
person who has no resources has to make
something that's very very very simple
and just as effective and that's sort of
the mentality I think that you see in
bootstrap companies like we don't have
the resources we've got to make
something that makes sense and we only
really have one shot at it so we're
going to do a good job and just do
exactly what we need and not all the
things that we could do
I think we probably hired a lot of
people if we had a lot of money that's
just something you tended to do in the
late 90s I heard so many companies so
we're going to staff up that is the
stupidest thing to say staff up
we're going to stat how about we're
going to hire somebody that we need what
is this idea of staffing up there was
this there's this thing going on the 90s
I remember people saying like we're
going to staff up to a hundred or people
are saying our company is this big when
they're talking about this big they're
talking about employees and it is very
easy it carried away with that and
thinking like that your inferior unless
you have a lot of employees so I think
that's something we probably done we
probably put money into marketing that
would have been wasting money we
probably put a ton of money at a PR that
would have been a waste of money and it
wouldn't have forced us to be creative
about how to get the word out which is
something we've learned how to do over
the past ten years without having to
spend money so we would have bought some
stuff and maybe done some things but i
think the real thing is we would have
missed learning the important lessons
that's what i think we would have
suffered most over
well my feeling is that like the stuff
that I like to talk about is really
about my business my industry so I'm not
my ideas don't necessarily make sense
for a restaurant or for you know Boeing
for example but their ideas o make sense
for me either so there shouldn't be
giving me advice I shouldn't be giving
them advice what I think those in the
software business which is the business
were in or a service business which is
the business a lot of people are in
outside of the technology world where
you don't have you don't have a factory
you don't have to have raw materials so
you don't damage any you don't have
these upfront costs that would typically
require you to raise capital if you
don't have those costs then you
shouldn't get the money that you might
need to spend to buy those things in the
software business you need a computer in
an internet connection it's like you
know a couple grand to get started it
but if I'm building a factory and I'm
making widgets I might need to you know
raise hundreds of thousands or a few
million bucks to make that big capital
expenditure so I think if you don't have
the raw capital expenditure requirements
then you should not be raising money up
front